welcome back to New rockstars I'm Eric
Boss and the Marvel's release new
footage in a featurette posting some
interesting questions around this MCU
follow-up to Captain Marvel into one
Division and Ms Marvel like why does
Carol Danvers want to remember some of
this stuff I'm gonna break down the new
shots to explain some details you might
have missed quick reminder that the SAG
after and the wga strikes are still
ongoing but the unions have confirmed
that entertainment journalists like new
rockstars are allowed to cover movies
and TV during that strike but please and
PTP enough is enough come back to the
table and negotiate a fair deal okay
let's take a look at the first part of
this teaser
it gets pretty lonely out here
I lead to regain the memories that the
cree took for me
so we see Carol Danvers flying in space
over this moon with a flirkin on her
shoulder at first I was like hey yeah
it's Goose but I did notice that the cat
they used in 2019's Captain Marvel was a
12 year old cat named Reggie and that
cat had an orange mouth this cat has a
white mouth that's because it ain't
Reggie anymore folks goose is played by
two cats named Nemo and Tango and
apparently Brie Larson is highly
allergic to feline dander so in addition
to everything in the shot being defects
even the cat on Brie Larson's shoulder
was put there with VFX they took it from
a different shot where I don't know did
they did they blow a fan on the cat's
face to make it squint like that and
fold its ears back and the flirkin does
not appear to be contained within
Carol's aura that allows her to fly
through open space like this but in the
July trailer we saw Goose floating open
space next to Carol so who knows flirkin
are just uncanny extraterrestrial
creatures whose Nails carry pocket
Dimensions now in the lower right corner
you can see some structure or Bass there
a moon base you say Steve Rogers on a
moon base Joaquin Torres Theory
confirmed I don't know if Carol is
flying over our moon our moon is covered
in a pale shade of dust this one looks
darker and rockier so I think this is
some remote colony where the cree has
set up some kind of archaeological site
and it's interesting how part of that
structure is a column reminding us of
the monolith that was discovered on
Earth's moon in 2001 A Space Odyssey
this column on the lunar surface which
we get another shot of in the July
trailer as Carol fights these Cree
soldiers before her swap might be part
of that diamond ship formation that
darban seems to be using in other shots
this actually looks like the same
location that we saw in earlier trailer
footage with Monaco Rambo as she faces a
group of Cree soldiers Monica falls
through a rift Above This Moon crashes
on this lunar surface and then holds up
her hands to protect herself from those
Creed so Carol's Moon flight will
probably lead to the moment that Kamala
Khan activates her bangle in that Ms
Marvel post credit scene that Nia
DeCosta also shot and Kamala swaps with
Monica into the astronaut suit outside
the saber space station by the untn grid
that's malfunctioning and then Monica
swaps with Carol here and ends up on
this Moon facing the cree and then Carol
swaps from the Moon into kamala's
bedroom in Jersey City so why are the
Korea on this Moon well in the July
trailer there were shots of Dar Ben
discovering the second Bengal on this
Moon covered in Moon dust as she snaps
it on her wrist and hammering it with
her Cosby Rod to unleash a purple blast
that lights up in an upward line I think
this is a Cree archaeological site and
they found the second bangle this could
be the inciting incident that causes the
cosmic entanglement that affects Carol
and Monica and Kamala in this movie they
are handcuffed in swapping places
because the Bengals are not together on
the same body and both are activated we
see Carol looking at photo of Maria
Rambo with an even younger Monica Rambo
boom Carol nicknamed Lieutenant trouble
and Carol playing with Monica in the
backyard Carol says she wants to regain
the memories that the cree took from her
and we see her waking up in a scroll
fracking pod the fuchsia tinted glowing
energy beams into her temples these are
what the squirrels use to contain their
captors in the secret Invasion series
and bore through their memories so that
the skull imposters could take the
humans Minds the squirrel Talos used one
of these on Carol Danvers in the opening
sequence of Captain Marvel to bypass the
cree brainwashing remember Carol was an
air force test pilot who worked with the
scientist Wendy Lawson on Project
Pegasus but Lawson was actually a Cree
scientist experimenting on the Tesseract
to help the scroll refugees hit an
Earth's orbit build a light speed engine
to find a new Homeworld but the cree on
Rog Jude Law attacks and cause Carol to
get hit with a blast of cosmic radiation
from that Tesseract and the onron
kidnapped her took her back to Hala and
altered her memory and told her that her
name was actually veers from her severed
dog tag from Carol Danvers remember how
old cell phones were giant cumbersome
bricks and now we have nice Sleek ones
that fit easily in our pockets well
wallets are the same way so say goodbye
to your bulky wallet of yesteryear and
say hello to ridge ridge has reinvented
the wallet and it is a massive
improvement over the ginormous
overstuffed wallets that we all grew up
with the ridge wallet is slim but
expands to hold up to 12 cards plus cash
Ridge wallets come in over 30 colors and
styles including carbon fiber burnt
titanium forged Ember and burnt Damascus
each wallet is built with RFID blocking
materials that protect your info from
digital pickpockets and adds an optional
air tag attachment so you'll never lose
your wallet again Bridge has 80 000 5
star review use in each wallet comes
with a lifetime warranty the rich team
is so confident that you'll like your
wallet that they'll let you test drive
it for 99 days and if you don't love it
send it back for a full refund and from
now until it's September 30th with every
dollar spent on the website before
you'll be entered to win a brand new
upgraded Ford Bronco or if you prefer
cash you could take 75 000 instead the
winner will be announced in October
enter for your chance to win and get 10
bonus entries by going to MyLink
ridge.com new rockstars and use my code
new rockstars for 10 off your order so
what memory is Carol so shocked to
recall in this shot if you look at Brie
Larson's expression she already knows
what Wendy Lawson was up to with the
Tesseract was there something else that
she learned about after that about the
Creed perhaps she at one point learned
of the crease Prem intelligence secretly
subverting Creed diplomacy to places
like xandar to actually unleash
militants like darbin to enact an
Annihilation wave protocol against a
scroll and against the Terence and that
could be the memory that the Supreme
intelligence or Yan Rog locked away in
Carol's mind now this featurette mainly
serves to catch us up on the past MCU
titles that these three characters
appeared in 2019's Captain Marvel for
Carol 2021's One Division for Monica in
2022's Ms Marvel for Kamala Khan but the
Monica section does have some new stuff
in it they rounded us to investigate
Earthbound anomalies now I can
manipulate wavelengths of the
electromagnetic spectrum I'm very happy
for you where's our daughter yes where
is obviously these lines are compiled
together from a few different scenes but
part of it is Monica and Carol catching
up on this room that I presume is aboard
the saber space station and Monica
describes her power as the ability to
manipulate wavelengths on the
electromagnetic spectrum hmm it sounds
like of these three women Monica will
have the most nuanced understanding of
how all of them are connected to Cosmic
radiation like she has spent the most
time studying it and so she might not
see things as like me an anomaly in the
rest of the world normal she views her
own anatomy in everything as part of an
interconnected system of flowing energy
that she can move in and out of and
manipulate and do things like these
bullets through her body I compare this
to the difference between doctor strange
and Wanda Maxima like Wanda might be
more powerful but Dr Strange who is a
doctor who spent more time studying and
analyzing his body's relationship with
magic is probably more nuanced about
manipulating it in creative ways which
brings us to the final Kamala section
how do you have this my grandma sent it
to me in the mail and then the rest of
the trailer really gets the most out of
that value of the rights that they
bought to the Beastie Boys Intergalactic
so we can't really play it here without
getting planned but we see Carol shaking
kamala's hand while Monica watches while
tinkering with some machine in a red
fidget spinner spins in her hand seems
like the three women are trying to
figure out a way to disentangle
themselves and then we get a slightly
expanded version of the three of them
fighting darbin and in this shot we see
Carol swinging the cosney rod at darbin
but darbin uses the Bengal to easily
repel it sending Carol hilariously
flying back like Gimli trying to
initially break the Ring of Power with
his ax but then this really cool move
where Dar Ben uses the bangle to absorb
one of Monica's blasts and then stores
that energy briefly but then beams it at
Kamala she's an effective military
General with great hand-to-hand combat
and she knows how to turn her enemies
strengths against her other enemies
please subscribe to all three channels
on the new rockstars Network you can
support us by grabbing some merch at
nerdright.shop follow me on all social
platforms that eat avos following
rockstars And subscribe to new rockstars
for more analysis of everything you love
thanks for watching bye
[Music]
foreign